المال صحه النساء صحه واذا اجتمع معا
الجميع سيكون في صحه وعافيه مش هيك
طبعا هذا الكلام قد يبدو من الحكم الشعبيه
لكننا نحن نتحدث علميا مشاهدينا هناك
دراسه امريكيه وجدت بان المال يطيل عمر
النساء فاعطوهن المال لعشنا اكثر لكن
العبره في التفاصيل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
نشرت البحث الذي وجد رابطا بين التحويلات
الماليه الى الدول الفقيره وبين معدلات
الحياه
الدراسات واسعه جدا طبعا وشملت سبعه
ملايين شخص في 37 دوله واكد تاثير
التحويلات النقديه على معدلات الوفيات نحن
بدورنا هنا بحثنا عن اجابات وتوسعنا في
موضوع المال والنساء في العالم وعن قدره
النساء على الادخار مقارنه بالرجال
التفاصيل مع علاء سرحان انصفنا على
في استطلاع لنيويورك لايف
وجد انه في عام 2022 ادخرت النساء في
المتوسط
31646 دولارا فقط سنويا مقابل 7000 دولار
وفرها الرجال فلماذا تدخر النساء اقل من
الرجال احد اكبر الاسباب انها تكسب اموالا
اقل للادخار وفقا لبيانات لبيانات عام
2021 من مكتب الاحصاء الامريكي فقد حصلت
النساء في المتوسط على
84% مما يكسبه الرجال بعد تحليل متوسط
الاجور للوظائف بدوام كامل ايضا تدفع
النساء ثمنا اكبر ليصبحن امهات اذا تعرضنا
لضربه كبيره في دخلهن بعد انجاب الاطفال
وهذا ما يعرف باسم ضريبه الامومه فيما لا
يقدم العديد من اصحاب العمل اجازه امومه
مدفوعه الاجر كذلك كثير من النساء يغادرن
سوق العمل باكرا لرعايه اطفالهن ما يعني
انهن خرجنا من حساب نظام التقاعد الذي
يشترط كسب الدخل للمساهمه لاحقا في الدخل
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
المراه اذا هل هي ايضا تنزعج وربما اكثر
من الرجل اذا لم تتمكن من ادخار المال من
جلب المال
جديد يمكن صار عنا اضطراب جديد هو القلق
على جني المال لان الاموال المال والمصاري
هي الرمز هي عامل رمزي
لتعويض اشياء كثيره في
نقص نفسي او نقص بالحياه المراه تعوض اذا
الرجل اعطاها وقال لها روح السوق هل تسعد
بذلك دائما
الجميع يصعد بهذا الشوبينج يعني حتى في
عنا علاج علاج الاكتئاب الشوكيني
يوميا
نشروها كثير وروجوا لها كثير حتى ما نبالغ
ونروح كثير بالموضوع لانه فعلا دراسه هاي
دراسات معموله بامريكا حصرا بامريكا وهناك
في خصوصيه للاقتصاد وله طريقه معينه في
العيش وفي التداول العمله في في البلدان
العربيه والدول الشرقيه تختلف
الدراسه بالولايات المتحده دراسه يعني
درست او اخذت عينه سبعه ملايين شخص يعني
كبيره جدا الشريحه كانت كبيره جدا تحدث عن
شبه قاره تقريبا طيب دكتوره فيما يتعلق
بالمال والسعاده هلا يقال بانه المال لا
يجلب السعاده او على الاقل انا بكمل هي
الجمله بقول قله المال تجلب التعاسه
هذه هي العلاقه علاقه عكسيه ما بين المال
والاكتئاب او السعاده والعكس
العلاقه موجوده ولكن
احيانا ترضيه احيانا عكسيه لانه احيانا
لما بكون قله شحب المال حيكون يعني
ابسوليوكلي تعيس بشكل كامل العائله المراه
مرتبط فيها الابناء يعني ما بدنا ننسى انه
المراه مو هي لحالها هي سعادتها كمان تاتي
مساعده الابناء لما بتحطهم بالمدارس لما
قدراني تعطيهم تشتريهم اللي بدهم لما
بتقدر تامنهم طبابه جيده فهذا بيعطيها
سعاده فهي مرتبط بس انه نحن نفتكر انه
المال
وتجيب اللبس يعني وهي ليست ماديه بس لانه
في هي بتفكر دائما بابنائه وهذا بيعطيها
سعاده لالها
اما لما بنروح للاكستريم بتصير المراه بس
هي مستهلكه للمال وهي بدها تحط المال
على كثير اشياء على كثير قلق داخلي
وتستخدمه كمعوض داخلي لنقص نفسي معين
لاضطراب معين عنده هون بنلاقي انه بروحوا
على الشوبينج كتير بروحوا كتير كتير على
الشوبينج المهووسين
خوفتيني على حالي بس يوميا ولكن معروف
الموضوع هون يعني له عده اوجه الوجه الاول
ممكن يكون صحيه اللي هو انه المراه بحاجه
الي تعيش حياه جيده من مستوى ماده جيد
لتقدر تعطي بشكل جيد وحتى في مقوله شعبيه
يعني كانوا جداتنا يقولوها وكثير بينصحونا
فيها الاجداد اللي هي انه عطي البنت اكثر
من الشب انه انت صرفي تكوني كريمه كثير
واغضقي على البنت بالمال واحرمي الشاب
الصبي لانه البنت اذا اعطيتيها هي حتنتج
اشياء حتتعلم
حتوفر
لاولادها حتفكر بعيلتها حتاسس للشيء ثاني
بينما الشاب اذا تضايق ماديا راح يروح
يشتغل راح يفكر انه يزيد تعلمه راح يفكر
يسافر رح يفكر يجني مال اكثر طبعا كله
بحدود يعني هاي مقوله شعبيه ولكن نحن
بعلميا منحكي بانه الاثنين بحاجه للمال
والاثنين بحاجه لحياه كريمه لانه الحضاره
فرضت هذا
العنصر شكرا جزيلا لك اذا المعالجه
والمحلله النفسيه دكتوره رنده رزق كانت
معنا شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات